utah mom selling almost 4 000 ounces of
breast milk as baby formula shortage
continues
this happened in uh utah alyssa chitty
has three freezers full of breast milk
look that's where we are now
that's what i mean i'm telling you we
are getting to a place where you can't
count on these big companies anymore
they're all in lawsuits there's two they
don't know any what they're too
disconnected from the customer
so people going right off the bag now
you want that you uh we got piss
milkshakes we got
fresh from i mean that is just from uh
firm to table baby right there
if you you go people going door to door
shooting each other for uh breast milk
titty milk
men are trying to do you see a lot of
gay men trying to and they don't even
have kids they're just trying to uh
do ejaculate out of their
nipples just crazy it's getting weird
man
and ladies if you got that strong hooter
baby juice it out
juice it out son
especially utah you up at that high uh
elevation
so if you don't think you could sell
that high elevation freaking bee skeet
baby you know what i'm talking about
breast milk if you don't think you could
sell that for a decent dollar baby
then you're wrong honey if you're
sitting around just doing wordle all day
and you got them freaking uh
them freaking forest lumps baby them
damn [ __ ] leche furnace is just
brewing
you know women are always like i want to
open up a business but you got two
businesses right there
you got them freaking little sternum
corporations baby juice them out
juicing [ __ ]
i'll buy a hot gram of breast milk off
of somebody
and especially this is this is basic
white utah breast milk man
that's just a basic homogenized [ __ ] you
get in there you get a nice urban lady
out there and she got those extra red
blood cells up in that
up in the milk
or you get a native american lady and
she got them you know what i'm saying
she got the forefathers in the milk you
know i'm saying you could really there's
definitely a way to um
what's that called uh uh
uh
it's a business thing
um
verticals they call it verticals
other ways you can make money on it but
yeah if you uh
yeah so there's way i mean there's
definitely some upsells in there you
know if you want that um
if you want that extra breast milk you
want that extra half ounce or you get
the daytime milk or you want that night
batch
now a lot of ladies don't realize if you
slang in breast milk on the internet
um
then you can also slang that night batch
you know
that uh if you want to sell that
nocturnal freaking uh that nocturnal
nipple beverage baby you know what i'm
talking about teddy milk
uh
we had this kid in our neighborhood he
couldn't talk much but he could say
teddy mayoke
and we'd always be like what do you want
he'd be like kidding me you
so anyway there's definitely a big
market out there for it because look
we're all becoming babies anyway
you know i'm an adult baby
half my friends are everybody i know
damn i would look if i hit a vending
machine and nobody was looking
that had me a little
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one
you